ん
みなさんご覧いただけるように私は音楽家です
私はこれまでに40年印象
フルート演奏可そして a 指揮者作曲家
そして音楽家として活動してきましたこの40年間の音楽家のキャリアの中で私は
200以上の介護施設を訪問しまして
非常に多くの認知症の患者さんの前で演奏しました
ディメンション社認知症という言葉です
この認証という患者さんのために演奏してきました
今日私の話は私が
認知症の患者様にどのようなことを音楽を使ってしているかをお話します
話を進める前にここで私のオリジナルの曲をご紹介しています
a これは衛兵
デザーてとラブという
音楽ですこれは世界中の見捨てられた愛ということですけれども
世界一の子供たち3知られた子どもたちに捧げた曲です
hey
a はい
衛兵
ko
hey
ああああああ
ana
皇居ありがとうございます
大祈ります
これはですね
私と皆さんの間での
これは非常に
普通に感じるものですけれども
これは認知症の患者さんのためには
なぜこういったことが必要なんでしょうか
これが必要なのは
認知症の患者さんに演奏する時にはあっ
ak と
尊厳を重んじる必要があります
そうしないと患者さんの心には通じないのです
ちょっと
今通じないわけですね
そして
私は
どのようにこうしたピン症の患者さんに演奏するかを
介護施設でどのように演奏するかをご紹介したいと思います
どのようにすればよいでしょうか
皆さん次第にお答えになられましたね
私がまさにいまー聴取の皆さんに演奏した方法が分かれるでしょうか
ではちょっと解説させてください3つの秘訣がありますひとつ目
私は皆さんの非常に近く
そしてももうすでに5あの手が触れるぐらいのこの地下車庫の距離感が非常に重要な
わけです
厚めの秘訣私は皆さんと同じ視線で演奏しました
見上げることも3下げることもなく同じ視線で演奏したということです
そして3つ目のポイントですけれども皆さんの目を見てずーっと目を見ながら演奏した
ということを築きだと
でしょうか
そうですこの3つの秘訣というのは非常に重要なわけです
特に人超の幹事さんに敬意と尊厳を示すのに重要なことです
ただ残念なことにこうした接し方というものを多くの介護施設で見ることはできてい
ません
ただ
それは全く見たことがないというものも間違っていると思いますなったら私は実際に
そうしたことを実践している方です
認証のことに関して2少しお話したいと思いますけれど皆さんが認知症の患者さんの
どのような行動かということについて少し解説たいと思います
もちろんその病院の
病気の原因にもよりますけれども大きく分けて2つの行動に分けることができます
まったく2つのことある違う行動を示されることがあります
一つ目はこのような感じです
一緒に一日中座って
行動も何も話すこともなく
ただ1日中医師に座っているという患者さんです
もしこのような行動を示しているのであれば非常にコミュニケーションが難しいわけ
です
なぜならばこうした患者さんというのはあまり反応がしなわけですね
誰とも話したこともまた話しかけられることもないので反応が薄いので難しいです2つ
女のコードはこのようなものでもう少し攻撃的な様子です
こうした患者さんというのはいつも怒って言ってイライラされていて
いつも不平多い不満を言ってそして怒鳴ったり
時として非常に気をつけなければいけないこともありますなぜならば
時として
顔殴られることがあるかもしれない患者さんなわけです実際にそういったこともあり
ます私は実際にそういった経験をしたいことがあります
数回そういった殴られたことがあります
ですので
覚えておけなければいけないのは
このような2つのまったく異なる行動を示される患者さんがいたとしても信じられない
かもしれませんけれども
このような行動の原因というものは全く同じなわけです
この2つのまったく異なる行動の患者さんの行動の原因というのは一つです
その理由とは何でしょうかその一つの理由というのは混乱とそして不安感です
患者さんはいつも混乱しているわけです
脳の中で大きな混乱が起きていてそして同時に何か大きな桜するを抱いでいらっしゃる
わけですですのでもしこのような混乱とか不安というものを取り除くことができれば
どのようにすればよいのでしょうか
私が今やっているようなことです音楽を奏でるのです
歌を歌うことですそして覚えてください非常に重要な3つの秘訣ここを忘れないで
いただければ
この3つのポイントを守りながら音楽を演奏するなれば
一家に早く音楽に反応されるから本当にあっという間に反応されるの驚くことになると
思います
信じられないかもしれないんですけれどもこれは薬にも勝るものです音楽はくせにも
勝るものです多くの薬を何回何所ものだとしてもそれはすぐに聞くことは即効性はない
ですねもしかしたら毒は一緒にして聞くかも知れませんけど即効性があるかもしれませ
んけれども
ん
通称の薬であればそのような走行性というものはありません
ただ音楽には即効性があります音楽は即効性があるのです
ですので私が話を終える前に一つの大事なてを最後に皆さんにお話したいと思います
世界手の多くの多くの認知症な患者さんがいらっしゃいますけれども皆さん是非生きて
以来します
内面つまり脳の中からだの中というのは生きている
その人間ということですそして
音楽というものがその記憶
また生命力を呼び戻すのは音楽音楽にそういった力があるということです私はこれを
強く信じていますし
もし私と同じようにするならば必ず皆さんも多くの認知症の患者さんを世界史の方
を救うことができると思いますご視聴ありがとうございました
dea